foreign
I gotta tell y'all this is the dumbest
thing I've seen I don't know when how
long does it take people to figure out
that these pieces of plastic called
credit cards are not there for you
how long does it take to figure out that
oh here's Bank of America Let's do an
on-air plastic surgery right now we're
just going to start chopping up carts
Bank of America that's two good things
to get rid of credit card and Bank of
America both stupid here's another
Platinum Bank of America we'll get rid
of that one too chase chase this okay
here's Home Depot they take cash by the
way you don't need this Countrywide
they're broke okay oh my God there's
another Bank of America we must collect
Bank of America old cards around here
these people uh just time to stop it is
time for a blastectomy America a
trillion
dollars in credit card debt I'm getting
airline miles no you're not you're in
debt
you're in debt a trillion dollars when
you do it with the student loans we call
it an epic pandemic crisis when we do it
with credit cards it's on the third page
of Fox's website it's a trillion dollars
of you buying crap you can't afford with
money you don't have to impress people
you don't even really like maybe you
should stop that I don't know
we've been doing this for 30 years I
feel like we're not getting anywhere
the progress It's not really showing up
Dave not really sure we're not really
moving the needle on America because
what I think has happened is I think
it's two things I think the the credit
card the game is a very real thing and
people say well if I'm gonna buy gas
might as well put on my credit card so I
can get cash back if I'm going to be
buying this anyways might as well put on
the credit card to get the airline miles
but it's kind of a Dr Phil thing so
how's that working for it's living in
that cycle and then there's a there's a
real truth that people are using those
to pay for for food and to pay no no no
no no no no no no yes they have the
money for food they're using these
because they don't want to cut off
Netflix
they're using these because they want to
go on vacation and they're broke that's
why they're using them it's the same
reason they've always been using them
you don't you cannot make an economic
case that people are actually have to
have a credit card for survival today
that's just not true it's not they in
their brains they keep saying
mathematical facts when you look at
their budget and you look at what's
going on and what they make and what I
mean everything in it it is it what's
hard is I'm like the math it is tight it
is hard but what happens is is the
standard of living that we're all
expected to live causes these things to
have to be a necessity in order to live
that standard of living and so to cut
to cut that well that means the average
American's living as stupid as their own
Congress is living well that they just
keep spending and spending and spending
like there's no tomorrow like there's no
Reckoning for this level of debt you
keep running up you got a trillion
dollars yeah 1.7 trillion in student
loan debt you got to now have a trillion
in credit card debt and then you can't
figure out why the average American
can't seem to get ahead well I think I
figured it out there's giving it all the
stinking Banks
that's why they got no money you work
your butt off your whole life and you
give all your money into a stupid Bank
and that's why you got no money it's not
a real hard formula no and I think that
and I think the perspective has to be
and the mindset shift has to be that if
you are someone listening and you're
like yeah I know but we're paycheck to
like we're we're not like doing
extravagant stuff we're just making the
end we're just living life and and so
the no debt philosophy even with credit
cards even with credit cards is to say
okay what like have a pretense scenario
pretend budget where you said we cannot
borrow anything we have to use the money
that hits our accounts then you that's
how you build your life you're right but
what happens is is we build our life
around and then you refuse to change it
to adjust for the variables and that's
what's hard with the student loan
payments coming back in October
there's going to be a rather huge
expense in the budget act like we're
surprised student loans came back hey
Christmas is always in December they
don't move it
and the student loans are coming in
October we've been telling you this so
I'm just saying there's a there's going
to be a a level of pain that a lot of
people are going to start to feel even
more in the next few months you know
what these are these are plastic denial
yeah yeah I'm in denial that I have to
deal with my crap yes and so I'm gonna
put it on a credit card and act like
nothing changed well stuff changed Bubba
yep and these people this is not
sophisticated this is straight up stupid
these companies are screwing you and
you're signing up for the trip
you're asking for it and you're getting
hammered at 18 to 28 percent and you
wonder why you make a hundred thousand
dollars a year and have no money because
you signed up for a stupid trip on the
stupid cruise and it's called the
plastic Cruise it's out of control you
guys they have lulled you to sleep
they've made you believe you have to
have one of these stupid things to exist
don't leave home without it well guess
what Daniel Boone left home without it
he made it okay all right you can make
it without these stupid things get you a
debit card pay cash for it get control
of your life get some autonomy from
these Banks they own your butt and you
gave them the deed don't give them the
deed to your butt they own you this is
the Ramsay show
[Music]